The Walking Dead is one of the most
popular shows on television yet some of
its stars are still mostly unknown for
instance consider lauren cohan
she's like maggie for five seasons but
how much do you really know about her
here are some fun things that most fans
of The Walking Dead probably don't know
about the career of one of the show's
toughest survivors she grew up in the UK
if you've heard lauren cohan speak out
of character it's probably a bit jarring
to discover she has an English accent so
what gives turns out that Cohen's mother
is English mystery solved
I was born in New Jersey my mom is
English my dad is American and I moved
to angleterre when I was 13 so I have a
bit of a bit of a both sides of the pond
supernatural star Cohen got her big
break in 2005 with a role in the film
Casanova then followed it up the next
year with a role in Van Wilder at the
rise of Tosh but it was returned as Bela
Talbot on supernatural that first
brought her the widespread attention of
television fans
unfortunately that attention was less
than positive an antihero who stole
magical artifacts and sold them to the
highest bidder Bela proved to be wildly
unpopular with fans after just six
episodes she was killed off it just
proves that fans are even deadlier than
zombies
moment of immortality it's no surprise
that the producers of The Walking Dead
approached Lauren for the role of Maggie
given that she's already had a
reputation in the industry for playing
strong women on horror shows case in
point
after ending her run on supernatural
Cohen landed a recurring role on the
Vampire Diaries as Rose an immortal
vampire sadly immortality isn't quite
what it used to be and after six
episodes she was stake through the heart
to skip a less bad luck for Chuck
in 2011 Cohen took a break from the
world of television horror and instead
became a villainous super spy on Chuck
in the role of Vivian McArthur Volkov
Cohen went full-on evil hiring hit men
to assassinate Zachary Levi's lead
character and even attempting to murder
his fiancee out of revenge okay you
don't do things like this please don't
do this I already have that doesn't
sound like sweet Maggie at all
commitment issues fun facts Coen almost
missed out on the walking dead because
she was under contract to a different
show back in 2011 Cohan films a pilot
for the CW called heavenly in which she
played a lawyer who teamed up with an
angel to fight crime or something
fellow CW stars Ben Aldridge and Ryan
Eggold were also cast but despite the
network nepotism the CW passed on
heavenly freeing her up to do the
walking dead instead
horror hater
perhaps the craziest thing about Cohen's
career even though all of her most
famous roles have come in horror stories
including her part in the feature film
the boy she isn't actually much of a fan
of the genre in fact she told media bowl
of our magazine that it scares her to
death I have a very weak stomach for
horror it's great but it's something
that you want to watch with a girlfriend
or a friend because you can scream with
somebody else you don't have to tell
that to the Walking Dead fans they
already know neighbors heard screaming
and gunshots coming from a family's home
so officers raced to the scene and mass
turns out the family was watching The
Walking Dead thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which of Lauren's TV roles is your
favorite